it is great to welcome back to the
program today Cass Sunstein who is a
professor at Harvard Law School also
author of the new book out today
on freedom Cass so great to have you
back on today it's great to be here I
really thank you so to get us into the
topic of the new book one of the things
I gathered from it and it will be
embarrassing if it was not your intent
is that freedom and liberty in the sort
of modern American libertarian ideal is
simply not enough to really have as
humans something closer to sort of
self-determination some higher level of
freedom did I correctly gather that from
what you wrote
yes so I love the way you phrased it
that it's not enough so the book is
broadly sympathetic to the libertarian
ideal which is the people of freedom of
choice but the inadequacy of that ideal
not the in correctness of the ideal but
the inadequacy of that ideal is I think
clearer every day so maybe first we can
start to define what the ideal might
look like and then maybe after that we
can justify what government's
involvement in that pursuit might might
be so to start with I mean when you
think about in in 2019 not in some kind
of abstract historical period but today
what is the the ideal of freedom that
would that we would hope to see for
humans I think it would entail at a
minimum two things one is freedom of
choice and the other is an understanding
of how you can get where you want to go
so freedom has limits of course so
people aren't free to punch other people
or to kill other people or to run red
lights and that's all very important to
acknowledge but bracketing the question
what exactly are the right limits on
freedom to allow people to go their own
way is a very good idea and also to add
and this is really the key point to help
people meet challenges of navigability
so to say that you
can choose your own doctor is is greige
and often you know very important but to
help people figure out how to find a
doctor or to find the right doctor is
essential often if people are going to
handle illnesses in a modern society
right so ignoring these again sort of a
caricatured libertarian ideas of humans
in a state of nature but in a modern
society how can we objectively define
where influence goes over the line and
starts to become coercive in some of the
ways that you're describing here that
that we should seek to obtain freedom
okay so one way to think about what is
inside the line of freedom promotion is
to focus very intensely on the idea of a
GPS device and why it's helpful a GPS
device you can ignore so if you think
it's preferred route is not scenic or is
not nostalgic you can choose the scenic
or nostalgic route it also is freedom
promoting in the sense that it allows
you to plug in your preferred
destination it doesn't choose the
destination for you that's up to you and
a GPS device is freedom promoting indeed
it's essential for people certainly in
places that are unfamiliar and they made
otherwise get lost and I think what it's
important to put a spotlight on is that
if you're trying to navigate let's say
the criminal justice system if you have
a problem with the law or the social
security system if you were trying to
get access to benefits or a hospital
where let's say your child needs help
because he or she is suffering from
anxiety or depression you need the
equivalent of a GPS device and you're
lost which is a form of unfreedom
without it so let's put a spotlight on
that as a major challenge for people all
over the world and sometimes private
organizations can provide what's
necessary sometimes not but the
disregard of the problem of navigability
is a serious problem for both theory and
practice there are no in terms of ahead
yeah so in terms of crossing a line
between promoting freedom and reducing
freedom if you tell people that their
ends are not the right ones they want to
go let's say to Manhattan and you send
them instead to Los Angeles that's a
form of coercion and it might have a
justification but the presumption should
be than it doesn't or you could pass the
line from freedom promotion to the
opposite let's say if you deceive people
if you tell them this is going to find
your way to let's say some economic goal
you have but in fact it's going to put
you in the poorhouse or if you
manipulate people by let's say playing
on their emotions in such a way as to
disrespect their capacity for their own
agency those things manipulation and
deception belong in the same extended
let's say evil family as coercion
noticing that in some cases you know
you're gonna deceive someone who's going
to kill you that's probably okay or if
you go to manipulate someone let's say a
child who is not doing what's needed for
him to overcome a terrible virus that
might not be the worst thing in the
world yeah so I I'm interested in a lot
of what you said there but to drill into
one particular element of it I've read a
lot of behavioral economics the work of
Daniel Kahneman and so many other people
and folks that you and many in our
audience are familiar with it seems to
me that in some of the to use your word
nudging that we can learn how to do
effectively with behavioral economics
there is arguably an element of
deception and deception again it's a
gray area because if someone is more
familiar with how some of these
psychological tools work they are able
to nudge others in ways that the others
don't recognize maybe playing
and tendencies that they have merely by
being human how do we draw the line
between when it's deceptive and when
it's not well I think we need to be
specific a guy very particular come to
terms with a concern so one kind of
nudge is a warning you know if you take
this medicine in too many doses you're
gonna get sick
that's not deceptive that's not honest
warning another one I think we would all
agree on that one yes so what I'm gonna
build is from easy ones and I'm gonna
struggle to find any hard ones and I
think that's going to be instructive so
I might be able to find some hard ones
but I'm gonna have to work at it
another form of nudge is information so
a calorie label McDonald's is nudging
you to yeah be a little more careful
before you have the high calorie foods
you can do that but it's like a GPS
device that's not deceptive a calorie
label that's information if there is a
reminder which is a very prominent kind
of dodge where you get a little maybe
beep on your cell phone if you're gonna
go over your credit-card limit or you'll
get some phone call from a company if
they think that let's say it's your
mortgage and you're not paying they'll
call you and say that's not deceptive so
the vast majority of nudges are very
hard I think to identify as deceptive
I'm not sure what you have in mind
exactly but it might be that you have in
mind a default rule where you're
automatically enrolled in let's say a
pension program or you're automatically
enrolled in some kind of program at work
which everyone's enrolled in it might
involve exercise it might involve
training something like that but you can
opt out let's say that I think would be
very hard to characterize as deceptive
unless it's it's secret and it's
unlikely to be secret because the secret
is going to come out in a hurry
when you are informed that there's a
program that you're supposed to attend
tonight so the challenge I think for
those who are rightly concerned about
the problem of deception is to identify
a nudge that qualifies as deceptive and
that challenge probably can be met but
in terms of the things that governments
have done you know in the last 15 years
and there are dozens of Nod units all
over the world I think it's very hard to
find one that there runs into the line
of deception can you talk a little bit
about the principles underlying some of
these nudges that would in your mind be
the most effective at achieving results
in other words we can imagine all sorts
of initiatives that have taken place we
could talk about soda bans that cities
for example have put into place we could
talk about a sort of default choice
circumstances like the one you refer to
but as a general principle what
influences behavior most effectively
okay so a ban wouldn't be a nudge so a
nudge is defined as freedom preserving
and one kind of motivation for this book
is to get a little more ambitious though
in not a lot of pages so unambitious and
length but ambitious in theory and
thinking about the relationship between
freedom and our capacity to get where we
want to go nudges that are preserving
freedom like information or default
rules can be extremely effective so we
have a program in the United States
which automatically enrolls poor
children in tree nutritionists
breakfasts and lunches that's incredibly
effective it's reduced the let's say the
non enrollment rate to the point where
in a given year as many as 10 million
kids which is a very large chunk of the
eligible population is in the program
that's super effective some information
campaigns are very effective there's a
law the credit card law
of 2010 the card act as it's called
which has a bunch of nudges involving
default rules and information disclosure
which is extremely effective at saving
American consumers over nine billion
dollars annually now for every
individual consumer it's not a whole lot
but population-wide we're talking about
a ton of money I wouldn't have a single
answer the question what's the most
effective tool if you make something a
crime and have a severe penalty attached
to it and the penalty is reliable that's
likely to be pretty effective in
preventing for example theft and assault
but even there with a certain population
of defiant people it might not work very
well so probably good to go area by area
the Social Security program whether you
like it or not it's very effective at
producing resources a lot of people have
concerns about solvency of the program
over time but in its run its had a
pretty good one as a benefit program and
so I think we want to ask you know what
is the what is the goal what are the
costs and what are the benefits for
cost-effectiveness the track record of
choice preserving interventions dodges
like educational campaigns information
reminders default rules is extremely
good actually to my surprise it's better
than for other kinds of programs the
extent we have data but the reason it's
better on cost-effectiveness grounds is
not that it's more effective it's that
it's more cost effective because
typically these interventions are really
cheap you can do them not quite on a
dime but pretty close to that
whereas to put up and running a program
of subsidies and fines and penalties
that's that requires a lot of resources
we are talking about the book out today
on freedom with the book's author Cass
Sunstein will pause our conversation
there and pick it up with him tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation today
with professor at Harvard Law School
Cass Sunstein the new book out yesterday
is called on
freedom Cass I think a great place for
us to go next is to start getting into
what the involvement of government
should be in guaranteeing or fomenting
the type of freedom that you're
describing is sort of essential for
humans in 2019 today um so let's let's
sort of start there I mean I think a lot
of people will probably be familiar with
your sort of political background what
is the strongest defense legally
speaking for government involvement in
ensuring the type of freedom and degree
of freedom that you advocate for in the
book I'd use some word softer than
guarantee and certainly softer than so
menteng more promoting and and the
strongest argument is that if the
government is providing information to
people it can save lives so to provide
information about risks associated with
let's say distracted driving it's not an
extremely expensive intervention it's
certainly a freedom promoting
intervention and we had in the United
States in recent years over 35,000
people died on the highways people those
people don't want to die they may be
making foolish choices but in some cases
they don't have the equivalent let's say
of a safety GPS and if the government
has clarity such as the seatbelt program
the very successful seatbelt programs
and it applies that to distracted
driving as well we'll have fewer dead
people and people will be making their
ways in a way that is freer in the sense
that their choices will be more informed
and that's a positive thing for
government to be doing in the area of
health generally to have cigarette
warnings of the sort we've had our
freedom promoting I would want more
aggressive warnings that sound seems as
if the current ones are a little too
anodyne that is boring and they don't
attract attention well enough but more
vigorous warning probably save lives if
400,000 people die to help people
overcome addiction
the opioid use would be freedom
promoting people who are getting into
opioids often or insufficiently
informed there's a role for government
and combating those risks it can do it
by helping people not to start in the
first place
with warnings and with maybe smaller
prescriptions in the first instance so
instead of getting 40 pills you get 10
that's likely to make a dent at least in
the opioid addiction problem with
respect to environmental risks involving
air pollution information of the sort
which government often promotes access
to about how the air is these days can
be both helpful for people who have
asthma problems and worse and helpful
for the private sector as a way of
promoting reductions so the kinds of
tools were talking about which involve
in the case of savings defaulting people
into savings programs sending you're
free to opt out but you're automatically
in government has incentivized that
having information environments where
people have clarity about what they're
getting and not so the our consumer
Bureau has had a mantra know before you
owe
I think that's a really good one if you
owe without knowing your your little
trap and if you're trapped you're not so
free so let's go a little further into
some that might get a little more
disagreement based on one sort of
political orientation let's talk about
health for example when we think about
initiatives to guarantee health care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
you have one side which I am sensitive
to sympathetic to which is that to truly
be free and to be able to pursue what it
is that you want to do you need to have
access to at least some level of health
care if you aren't able to get that care
that's going to restrict your freedom on
the other side you have people who say
well as soon as you mandate payroll
taxes for for example employees and
employers in order to get people that
health care you are taking away some
degree of freedom from those employees
and employers
employees and employers to decide what
to do with the money that they make how
do we start to unpack that and find what
the balance is okay so what unfreedom
is about is what I regard as the great
neglected component of freedom that
lawyers my own people
economists philosophers political
scientists and you know all of us
thinking about freedom have neglected
which is the problem of navigability and
I don't love that word because as too
many syllables but it's instructive in
suggesting that if you don't know how to
get where you want to go you are to that
extent less free and that people whose
children suffer from health problems
including mental health for people who
are suffering economically they want
training or they want education the
problem of navigability is often
obstacle number one so that's what I
want to put a spotlight on the more
ambitious claim that you've raised which
is that if you don't have access to the
healthcare system because you're poor or
something you're on free or that there
should be an employer mandate in order
to promote freedom on the part let's say
of those who otherwise are deprived of
access to health care have a deprivation
of freedom I have for present purposes
nothing to say about that today it's a
an honor in ways I think we haven't yet
while saying let's bracket that one can
we maybe zoom out a bit then and think
about conceptually the idea of positive
and negative freedoms in this
conversation the idea of where we kind
of couch the debate about freedom to do
something and when that starts to
impinge on freedom from something for
somebody else I mean I think the the
debate that fortunately now is a little
bit less timely than it was five years
ago about religious freedom versus
freedom
to discriminate against people on the
basis of perceived a real LGBT status
which is an interesting freedom to and
freedom from discussion where do you
draw the line there well if you have
someone who is unable to find her way
let's say to job training which she
badly wants then I say there's an
obstacle to freedom
you can say that the absence of
navigability is an insult to positive
freedom that she's making a claim on
someone's resources to find a route that
that's that's fair I think whether it's
right I'm not completely sure but it's
it's not obviously not right so insofar
as we say that helping people find a
route to their preferred destination
calls for a form of positive freedom I
don't have a particular complaint but
I'm not sure it's true because if
someone can't find their way to their
preferred destination their negative
freedom may be interfered with depending
on what the obstacle exactly is and
who's putting it there so you can see
the the claim that is that it's an
unusual claim so the reason I did the
book is that I want to say something
that's that's not been said a thousand
times before the claim is that the
navigation problem is a freedom problem
there's a debate about which there are
many thousands of pages spilled probably
every month which is about the most of
them thank goodness are not published
about the positive and negative freedom
debate my view about that is that it has
a large semantic dimension which makes
it less interesting where the advocates
of positive freedom claim freedom
entails or right to things and the
advocates of negative freedom say
freedom entails right freedom
from impositions of various sorts this
on my view has a definitional character
which means what's underlying it
substantively is is not that clear
clearly the Friends of positive freedom
say this is a good thing and the Friends
of negative freedom are not that excited
about positive freedom but they can't
the net Friends of negative freedom
can't earn the victory by stamping on
the ground and saying that's not freedom
they after in the victory by saying that
what a society ought not to be providing
those things because those societies are
poor less prosperous there's less
Liberty of the kind they value and then
then then we're talking about substance
rather than that is about what society
should look like rather than about the
meaning of terms when we think about any
restriction on freedom how should we or
to what degree should we be considering
the possible negative externalities of
such a decision beyond sort of as you
say the specific substance of a decision
ok so there's a view let's call it so
2018 which is that a restriction on
freedom consists of blocking people
let's say through force from getting
where they want to go sure that's
inadequate there's two thousand nineteen
view is that people if people can't find
their way to the place where they want
to go either because of some literal
obstacle to acquiring the knowledge or
because of some access to the relevant
information problem they are to that
extent unfree and for people who suffer
from addictions this is particularly
clear and there's a lot of talk on the
part of alcoholics and drug addicts that
they are enslaved and I think that's
fair that's what the experience is like
they need something that will liberate
them 2019 talk
back to 2018 there's a view that well
precedes 2018 that if you are imposing
harm on others there's a legitimate
basis for interference with your let's
say 2018 freedom and that goes back to
John Stuart Mill was a libertarian of
our sort and who believes with
modern-day libertarians that if you are
engaging in behavior that proposes harm
to others then it's okay to do something
it might be a corrective tax and may be
fine it might be a law and I have no
problem with that and that is correct I
would add only that in the book does
touch lightly on this that in cases in
which an individual is imposing harms on
his or her future self of a certain
magnitude and it's really clear then the
argument for coercion needs to be
explored
I think explored with skepticism but
explored so if you have someone let's
say who's buying appliances that are
relatively cheap but they're gonna cost
them a whole lot over the lifetime of
the use of the expenditure wouldn't put
them in jail or fined them for that but
there might be an argument for energy
efficiency standards which will move the
market in directions that will help
consumers over the long term I don't
want to say that the argument for energy
efficiency standards is airtight
but in principle it's it's an empirical
question in large part and it's worth
exploring the book is called on freedom
we've been speaking with the book's
author Cass Sunstein professor at
Harvard Law School we are linking in the
description for the YouTube video for
the interview directly to the book Cass
thank you thank you so much for joining
me today really a pleasure thank you a
great pleasure